what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu
spiderman no way home has been in
theaters for over a month now coming up
on two months and the writers and the
production team and the actors they're
all doing tours right now and they're
all doing interviews and of course as
they do interviews and get asked
questions more about the film comes out
including what we actually missed scenes
that almost made it to the final cut but
were cut out right before they decided
on what the finale was and for those
mysterio fans we almost got mysterio in
the final battle for spider-man no way
home and not just mysterio but some
other villains as well and sadly we do
actually have a little bit of a tease of
what this could have looked like as well
as marvel has released official concept
art of this final scene and mysterio in
it fighting doctor strange the writers
have shed some light on what the scene
actually was and how mysterio and rhino
came into the final battle of spider-man
home so let's break down what they said
and of course if you're new and you love
marvel be sure to subscribe and hit the
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest videos so in an
interview with comicbook.com spider-man
no way home writers chris mckenna and
eric sommers talk about how we almost
actually did have a sinister six and in
this interview they explained that they
kept going over who should the sixth
villain be who was going to be the final
member of the sinister six and before
they decided to not have a sixth member
the two options that they had on the
table were going to be either mysterio
or rhino and i personally would have
loved to see mysterio show up in
spiderman no way home because it would
have been a different mysterio it
wouldn't have been the same quentin back
that we saw in spider-man far from home
and this would have added a bit of a
twist to everything because in that
final battle people probably would have
seen mysterio which would have added
some confusion considering the fact that
he's dead in the mcu or should i say the
main timeline but perhaps the biggest
thing that we were robbed of because
this did not make the final cut was a
fight between mysterio and dr strange as
i mentioned official concept art for
spider-man no way home has come out and
it shows mysterio fighting doctor
strange at the statue of liberty now
this would have been a very interesting
battle because doctor strange is magic
but mysterio is not he's an illusionist
he's the master of illusions so it would
have been interesting to see how he held
up against doctor strange using his
illusions would this have been confusing
to doctor strange or would it have
simply been just a walk in the park for
doctor strange true magic versus
illusions despite whatever it may have
been i'm sure it would have looked
phenomenal now instead of getting
mysterio or rhino as the sixth member of
the sinister six they kind of came
through at the end where the multiverse
starts to kind of tear apart and all of
the villains who know that peter parker
spider-man are coming through in a real
quick blink and you'll miss it moments
we can see people like craven the hunter
and of course mysterio and rhino are
there as well so ultimately that is what
they decided on instead of having that
one last member of the sinister six
however the writers do go on to say that
they really thought about doing the
official sinister six in this movie
chris mckenna says who is the sinister
six here if you want six you can always
say venom was the sixth member if you
want he's in the tag he made it into the
mcu but he never made it out of mexico
there was always that talk of should we
be doing officially the six now
ultimately they didn't but here's
something that is truly interesting the
writers also revealed that the green
goblin was originally not the main
villain of the film but they lost
characters and as they lost certain
characters the green goblin became the
main villain of the film so you have to
wonder who they lost and if they lost
them because sony and marvel are
actually planning on using them for an
official sinister six movie sony
executive producer amy pascal once said
about two years ago that if you look at
everybody in the mcu we actually have
all of the members of the sinister six
already so perhaps that's why we didn't
get an official sinister six in this
movie because sony and marvel have other
plans for the sinister six and of course
a new spider-man trilogy has been
announced with tom holland perhaps
they're waiting for him right around the
corner in another movie but i would have
really liked to see mysterio in that
final battle go up against doctor
strange and the spider-man but let me
know what you think about this in the
comments down below would you have liked
to have seen rhino show up or mysterio
or perhaps maybe even both a sinister
seven let me know your thoughts and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest news for live updates you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you